no there's this idea in the minds of
people sometimes they articulate it
sometimes they don't is that you know
what they say okay okay all Muslims are
not terrorists 1.6 billion people in the
world are Muslim they can't all be
terrorists okay I'm accepting that I
understand you guys are not all bad
but all terrorists are Muslim that's
something that many people are thinking
in their mind they think that you know
what terrorism somehow is been
monopolized by Muslims is that they're
the only terrorists that exists in the
world happens to be Muslims if there's
something going on with the religion you
know something is not right there aren't
Christian terrorists and atheist
terrorists and Buddhist terrorists and
the problem with people's beliefs is
they're only getting their information
they have this in their mind but it's
not a reality they're getting their
information from what they see on TV
what they see on the news quote-unquote
what this propaganda that's being spewed
about Islam usually has a political
objective it's usually tied to some
either money invasion of a country some
type of oil that you know we need to go
and take over from such-and-such country
and it's not the reality you find
terrorism is something which is
historical it's been practiced by people
of all religions and people who practice
no religion whatsoever and if you go
when you just analyze every single
terrorist incident that has ever taken
place in the last hundred years in the
last 50 years you find that it's not
dominated just by Muslims there are
Buddhist terrorists who are terrorizing
Muslims in formerly known as Burma in
Myanmar right now the Rohingya Muslims
are being terrorized by them there was a
Time magazine article with a Buddhist
monk on the cover saying is this the new
face of terrorism that doesn't mean that
all Buddhists are terrorists but it
means that there are Buddhists
terrorists out there are there Christian
terrorists absolutely you go and check
the FBI database and you find how many
terrorist groups exist
check out the army of God for example
their website is fully functional army
of god calm you
check out what incidents they've done
Centennial Olympic Park bombing several
other bombings and things like that
there's a lot of terrorism going on
people don't know about this I worked in
a mosque where in 2002 the King Fahd
mosque in color City Los Angeles was
about to be bombed by the Jewish Defense
League the Jewish Defense League is a
known terrorist organization in the
United States of America according to
the FBI
now they caught them before they blew up
the mosque we thank God that that
happened but people don't generally
associate Jews with terrorism they don't
associate Buddhists with terrorism they
don't associate Christians with
terrorism because the primary news
source that people have is usually
something that's very biased and it's
usually just seeing these flashing
pictures of this Muslim guy angry guy
with the beard and all of a sudden
there's no facts when you conclude in
your mind through these pictures that
you know what it looks like all
terrorists that I've ever seen happen to
be Muslim that's because the only
terrorists you've ever seen or known
about is coming from Fox News or CNN or
whatever other you know station that you
happen to be watching for your
quote/unquote information about
terrorism go read a book about the
history of terrorism go and check and
see how many different terrorist
incidents have happened just in the
United States of America the Capitol
building has been bombed the the
Pentagon has been bombed the LA Times
newspaper building has been bombed who
are doing all these bombings for the
last hundred years these are not Muslims
these are Americans some of them
Christians some of them eight years some
of them socialists some of them
communists some of them people of
different religions it's very important
for us to zoom out and look at
statistics and make make us understand
how little we really know about
terrorism today and the history of
terrorism and the motives behind
terrorism so we can get this idea out of
our mind that whatever we see on TV that
just happens to be the reality of what
exists in this world so free your mind
from that
you